you mentioned would we seed another
planet with life is it possible that our
planet proceeded with life from
elsewhere so what the the proposition I
made I like to think of it as
protospermia rather than panspermia
because it seems it's even more the more
proto-state than the acknowledging
because in in Pan's permia you still
have a self
right you still have something that is
very even a cell to me would be very
Earth-like yeah right I'm I'm talking B
I'm talking at sub-seller level in in
the proposition of uh
spreading chemistry so spreading
chemical ingredients not spreading life
exactly it will be more like the
fertilizer that is well adopted and
compatible with that planetary body in
panspermia you're still imagining either
an entire bacteria or microbe or a
celled or something that is DNA which is
still terrible so in that sense that
would
that doesn't matter to you because it's
it's chemistry that's the initial
conditions doesn't matter how the
initial conditions came to be they are
what they are and let's go from there
yeah and there's all kinds of
fascinatingly different
initial conditions in terms of chemistry
at different planets yes but but in
terms of past perme I mean obviously
that's that there's going to be always
room for that those sort of discussions
or there will be uh those discussions
will always be present I think in any
life in Universe debates but the problem
I have with transpermia is that it
removes the problem from
the planet to somewhere else it makes it
a very difficult to answer
scientifically right you you are just
you just took the problem away from this
planet and uh
formulated in a way that I cannot go and
try to understand in the lab doing
experiments or even through models does
it though so I've heard brilliant
biologists like yourself say that but I
I just to me
okay here's how I think of Earth so I I
actually am able to hold all these
possibilities in my head and all of them
are inspiring to me I kind of think
there's a possibility that Earth is just
an experiment by a graduate student by
an alien graduate student like so I know
the exact episodes of Star Trek you're
talking about but like there is some to
me that's inspiring if we are but that's
not what's uh panspermia is about that
you're talking about my proposition
that's not what panspermia is what's
past problem it just oh life just came
from elsewhere
still that's interesting because there's
still giant leaps that happened on Earth
it seems like beyond the initial
primitive organisms like eukaryotes I
don't think panspermia usually
articulates at the level of eukaryotes I
think they talk about the bacteria
primarily I think so right so that
that's still interesting because all the
different leaps of evolution still
happen here on Earth that's still
interesting yeah but it's I mean it's
definitely
um
interesting to listen to but I I
wouldn't uh place it you know I wouldn't
know how to place it in the studies of
origin of life I guess or yes I will
place it you have the initial conditions
for the origin of life and you try to
create life in that way that you've
described in the five components and it
keeps failing
see what what pantspermia allows you to
do is to also consider the question
maybe there's missing components how do
you answer that question
to exploration and through science yes
looking outside looking outside of Earth
looking at the fundamentals of chemistry
and physics how do you understand that
with fundamentals of chemistry and
physics how do you understand how do you
understand gravity but you're talking
about panspermia right just I don't
understand how would you it's different
than if if you think it's similar to
looking for a life in the universe is
that what you're thinking no I'm saying
there's a missing component that came
from elsewhere but the whole entire
organism is not a mystery component like
that right I mean when you're thinking
about origin of life no no that that's
an assumption your your assumption is
all the ingredients for the origin of
Life are here on Earth now I tend to
believe that most likely that's the case
I'm just saying it's inspiring to think
that there is some ingredients
you're going to push back because that's
not past permia that's promised but see
okay so think
but yeah I'm also kind of fun to push
back on you uh no I I I understand I
understand I understand if if actually a
living organism
ended up here from elsewhere that means
a lot of the exploration we're doing
here with the ingredients that we know
will not give us the clues to the
um to the origin of life but it just
seems like
it's still very useful to try to create
life here and then we'll see wait a
minute don't you think we'll be able to
prove not prove but show that past Burma
is very likely
like if we just keep failing we
understand biology deeply I don't I
don't think so I mean there there will
be the failure is is not going to
indicate that this must have been I
don't think anyone will put the problem
to some some something else just because
our failures our experiments failed so
failure means we don't understand the
chemistry deeply enough yeah and we've
given the progress we made and how many
brilliant people are working on this
right now and it's definitely more I
would say that we are approaching this
problem in more broader ways with
different ways possible I'm confident
that we will get there for for us again
very interested in if
early souls and first cells and what
followed the origin of life but we
cannot be given that it's a Continuum
that's the between the origin and
emergence of first cells it's hard to
separate these two ends from one another